اذا البرتغال انتصرت على غانا ورده ربما
على المشككين في وضع المنتخب البرتغالي
على في ظل ازمه كريستيانو رونالدو الاخيره
المنتخب البرتغالي اللي كان قادر انه
يتعامل الى حد كبير مع منتخب غانا ولكن
كاد ان يتلقى هدف في اخر دقائق لولا ستر
الله يعني فا يعني هو انتصار مهم ثلاث
نقاط مهمه في بدايه المشوار ولكنها ليا
تكفي ولا تغني من جوه هي نقاط ربما نعم
كامله ولكن الاداء عليه علامات استفهام
كبيره عليه اشارات تعجب كثير جدا من قبل
الجماهير اداء دفاعي غير معقول من جانب
المنتخب البرتغالي وغير مقبول وخصوصا من
روبن دياز الذي يعني ما قدم احسن المواسم
وهذا الموسم مع مانشستر سيتي بالمقابل
هجومي المنتخب البرتغالي كان قادر يغلق
فرص كان قادر يسجل اهداف وكان قادر يرجع
رغم انه غانه ولكنه كان قادر يرجع ويسجل
هدفين وينتصر بالمباراه بثلاثه اهداف
مقابل هدفين
حديث الاول راح يكون عن كريستيانو رونالدو
كريستيانو رونالدو دخل الى هذه المباراه
متوتر مبين عليها علامات التوتر كان حتى
البودي لانجوج او لغه الجسد تبعه مبين
فيها ان هو مش مرتاح انه هو بيحاول يثبت
للناس ان هو موجود ان هو قادر يسجل قادر
يقود منتخب البرتغال وكل هجمه كان يضيعها
لما يضيعها انفراد بدايه المباراه وبعدها
اضيع كره راسيه ايضا كانت علامات ربما
العصبيه او الحاله من الغضب الشديد بادي
على وجهه وبالتالي هذا شيء بيدل على انه
رونالدو داخل المباراه مش مرتاح اللي حرر
رونالدو من خلال الضغوطات كانت ركله
الجزاء اللي هو تحصل عليها وهو سددها
بنجاح في مرمى المنتخب الغاني وبعد ذلك
بدانا نرى ربما تحسنا طفيفا باداء
كريستيانو رونالدو مش تحسن كبير ولكن تحسن
طبيب خلانا نحكي وهو اللي ساهم الى حد ما
تاثير اجابه على عقليه لاعبين المنتخب
البرتغالي خلال هذه المباراه عندي علامتين
استفهام على تبديلات
المدربين المنتخب البرتغالي ومدرب منتخب
غانا مدرب منتخب البرتغال بدايه تسرع جدا
بعمليه الثلاث تبديلات التي قام بها او
ثلاثه تبديلات باخراج وافلكس وكريستيانو
رونالدو و برناردو سيلفا لانه باخراج لها
هؤلاء اللاعبين رفعوا الضغط عن دفاع غانا
وسماح للمنتخب الغاني انه يهاجم بشكل كبير
جدا ونجاح بتسجيل هدف الثاني منتخب غانا
وكان قريب من تسجيل هدف الثالث لولا انه
اللاعب اللي قطع الكره من الحارس في نهايه
المباراه ربما صارت في حاله من انه فقد
التوازن واضاء الكره في نهايه اللقاء
بالمقابل مدرب المنتخب الغاني تبديل بخروج
قدوس وخروج اندريه ودخول جوردن اي هو دخول
بخاري كان تبديل غريب جدا بمجرد ما صار
التبديل راسا تلقى منتخب غانا الهدف
الثاني ربما بعد ذلك بدقيقه او دقيقتين بس
مش اكثر من ذلك بالمقابل ايضا فرناندو
سانتوس سؤال لماذا يبدا فليكس على حساب
ليو شفنا اليوم لما دخل على ارضيه الملعب
كيف قدر شكل البرتغال هجوميا قدر يخلق
خطوره قدر يسجل هدف بعد ثواني من دخول الى
ارضيه الملعب لاعب سريع مراوغ شايفين
اداءه مع ميلان بالمقابل جواه فليكس بشوت
المباراه الاول اضاء هجمتين خطيرتين جدا
نعم سجل هدف في شوط المباراه الثاني ولكن
اعتقد انه لو ليا وبدا المباراه اساسي كان
ممكن انه البرتغال تطلع بنتيجه افضل من
ذلك بكثير وتخلص المباراه باريحيه اكبر من
ذلك بكثير بكل امانه المنتخب الغالي يتفوق
في منتصف الملعب خلينا متفقين على هاي
العمليه وجود قدوس وبارتي واللاعب الاخر
اللي كان موجود في منتصف ملعب ايضا غانا
كان مساهم بشكل كبير باداء المنتخب الغاني
بتالق المنتخب الغاني في وسط الملعب خلال
هذه المباراه وتفوق على المنتخب البرتغالي
غانا قدمت المباراه جيده اعتقد انه هذه
افضل المباراه للمنتخبات الافريقيه في كاس
العالم حتى الان همم ادائه هجوم جيد صناعه
فرص سرعه في نصف الملعب دفاع انا منيح
كذلك ما كان سيء دفاع غانا والبرتغال
علامات استفهام كبيره على الاداء حتى في
منتصف الملعب برونا الفناندس مين شاف
برونا فنانديز اليوم بالملعب اعتقد ما حدا
شاف رونالدو اليوم حتى برناردو سيلفا لم
يكن برناردو سيلفا اللي بيمسك الكره من نص
الملعب وبيطلع فيها للهجوم وبيسجل هدف وهو
بيصنع هدف ما كان هذا برنامج سيلفا
اختيارات المدرب اثرت بشكل كبير برايه على
اداء المنتخب البرتغالي في هذه المباراه
على كل حال هي ثلاث نقاط مهمه بالنسبه
للبرتغال خساره بصراحه ما بعرف هي مستحقه
ولكن كان ممكن يتجنبها منتخب غانا همم بس
اكيد راح تعطيه دفعه معنويه كبيره طارق
لامتي بعد المباراه قال بتصريحات خاصه
لسينان انه نحن بالعكس هذه المباراه
اعطتنا دفعه معنويه جيده جدا وراح نقدر
انه نتعامل مع المباراه القادمه بشكل افضل
من ذلك هذا كان كل شيء بخصوص مباراه
البرتغال وغانا اليوم من هنا من امام ملعب
تسعه سبعه اربعه هنا في قطر خلينا نشوف شو
راح يصير من المباريات القادمه
شو راح ترسل هاي المجموعه